the Federal Reserve is expected to raise
interest rates yet again today to try to
curb inflation even as the latest
numbers show that inflation is in fact
slowing down Ed O'Keefe is at the White
House for us where the President says
the threat is still with us Ed Good
morning Tony good to see you good
morning President Biden says the harsh
inflation consumers have been
experiencing is expected to ease off but
it's going to take some time warning it
may take until late next year
after a year of record high prices for
everything from housing to handbags
there are more signs inflation is easing
off overall prices jump 7.1 percent in
November compared to a year ago that's
down from October and off the peak in
June prices are dropping for gas down to
an average of 321 a gallon used cars and
utility bills but food prices remain
high with baked goods fruits and veggies
all costing more President Biden who's
made fighting inflation a top priority
says it'll take most of next year to get
prices back down make no mistake prices
are still too high we have a lot more
work to do but things are getting better
headed in the right direction but many
Americans are facing a 1-2 punch higher
costs due to inflation and Rising
interest rates sparked by the Federal
Reserve I feel like I'm not able to
really make movement in my in my debt
the way that I would like to with the
interest rate on credit cards now at
record highs Micah Peterson is
struggling after helping bail his
brother out of jail he took on thirty
thousand dollars in debt and he's been
paying it down but I can't believe that
if this was three four or five years ago
when before we saw all these changes in
our economy I would be able to make more
of an impact and you know be a little
bit less a little bit more debt-free
Greg McBride of bankrate.com says higher
interest rates make it difficult on
consumers it's like pedaling into a
progressively stiffer headwind it just
more and more uh of is being chewed up
by interest so to pay down the balance
uh you just have to Pedal that much
harder so all eyes today are on the
Federal Reserve and what it might say
about future rate hikes the central
Bankers led by chairman Jerome Powell
obviously trying to walk a tightrope
here bring down inflation but not push
the country into a recession Nate I hear
you on that Dad thank you